[Music]
hey Developers
we are down to our last tech talk that
will be live broadcast also to our
audience on the internet from Europe
Middle East and Africa
and for this last session let's learn
how to easily move from raw data to
machine learning and we'll hear about
this from our Google Cloud machine
learning product specialist kamuma
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome to the final
session on how to move from raw data to
ml faster with bigquery and vertex AI
first off let me introduce myself my
name is kamuma I manage the customer
engineering team for the South India
region specialized on machine learning
and AI
so let's begin the session how do you
move from data to machine learning
so what are the barriers between data
and machine learning that we often see
with our partners and customers and even
internally at Google which continued to
slow innovation
first let's start with data data is
often big and multi-formatted which
means there are many data silos
copies of data and makes data hard to
discover and extract value from
then aim ml systems are often isolated
from data leading to more needs of
integration security risks and
unsuccessful machine learning
deployments
so first how do you get from data to
machine learning let's look at the data
piece you need the data engineering
steps this includes data ingestion data
preparation data storage and often some
sort of data cataloging
and then you move to data analysis where
you need data exploration data
pre-processing to gain Data Insights
so how do you extract even more value
with machine learning
first you have the model development
step where you do feature engineering
model training
register your models in a model registry
and some type of model evaluation
and then you do ml engineering with
model serving model deployment and model
monitoring with features stored in
between
and finally you have insights activation
where you can use your learnings from
your machine learning and data analysis
to influence business decision
customer decisions and serve Downstream
applications
we've also added the horizontal
component of orchestration so you could
automate your ml pipelines and data
pipelines with CI CD
so this slides show how you could build
entire data to ml Journey with data
Cloud Google data cloud and I would like
to say that this is not all of our
services
provided on our platform this is just an
example of some of the tools that you
can use to get value from your data on
gcp
so on my right here you have any type of
data that can be ingested inside gcp and
more so your data could come from
corporate and third-party systems
e-commerce SAS applications iot devices
social media or geospatial data and more
and then it could get ingested on gcp
with data engineering using dataproc and
data flow and I'd like to point out here
that dataproc is a serverless version of
spark and dataflow is a serverless
version of Open Source beam and this is
indicative of all our services where we
try to have a managed version of Open
Source software to have the most open
platform available
next we have done analysis using
bigquery or the data analysis tool of
your choice
you could do model development on vertex
Ai and bigquery ml ml engineering on
vertex Ai and insights activation on
vertex side looker app engine or other
Downstream services
this can help with any Innovation here
are some that we listed but I'm sure you
have some in mind or some are ready in
production so decision making app
development SAS applications exception
management and so on
you also have the horizontal
orchestration layer to automate each of
these steps to scale and put these
models into production we propose here
Cloud composer or vertex AI pipelines
how composer is an imagined version of
Open Source software as well and vertex
AI pipelines supports two open source
SDK tensorflow extended as well as
kubeflow pipelines SDK
and we really designed and built this
platform to meet the needs and expertise
of various users that you see listed
above and more so data Engineers machine
learning Engineers data scientists data
analysis business users to add value to
the customer
so how do you get to this full ml
production system
we had designed a journey from crawl
walk and run this is very high level but
we hope it'll resonate with you
so first we were proposed to start with
vertex AI workbench
virtus AI workbench is a Jupiter based
fully managed scalable enterprise-ready
data science experience with easily
enforceable policies and user management
so we see with our users that they could
get to production ml models faster with
vertex I workbench compared to
traditional Jupiter notebooks and this
is the case because we've added
extensions to simplify data access so
you could seamlessly and out of the box
connect to your data source in bigquery
Google cloud storage and other data
sources
we also support In-Place data
Exploration with SQL and Spark queries
from a syntax aware autocomplete enabled
notebook cell
and also we support multiple
environments out of the box
so whether you're using tensorflow pi
torch or spark you could run any of
these engines from the same vertex AI
workbench instance
this means you don't have multiple need
to have multiple servers for different
environments
and this saves you time from maintaining
and keeping running multiple servers as
well and costs
so now that you can crawl with the
workbench how can you walk and start to
train and deploy your models
so this is an illustration of how you
could do this on vertex AI
so your data could come from Big Lake if
it's tabular it could come from bigquery
or it could come from Google Cloud
Storage
then you do your data engineering step
you could use one or all of bigquery
data proc and data flow
and then you move on to model training
on automl vertex AI custom models or
bigquery ml
and then you can register your models in
vertex model registry and deploy these
models for batch inference on bigquery
amount or vertex AI endpoints for batch
and live inference to power your
Downstream applications
I'm also now very excited to announce
that model registry on vertex AI is now
generally available
so vertex AI model registry allows you
to have models registered from automl
bigquery ml or vertex AI custom models
so all your models could be in one place
for easy reuse tracking and model
versioning
we also allow you to add labels and
aliases to your models to facilitate
model discovery
another feature is that you could
seamlessly deploy your models to vertex
AI endpoints using the UI or via a
Vertex CI SDK
and finally all this is integrated into
our vertex AI SDK so you really have a
unified vertex AI experience
so how do you really run with machine
learning
we've added here to the previous diagram
the vertex AI pipelines Cloud build and
CI CD block up top
so what this means is that now you can
automate each of the steps in your
machine learning pipeline you could
substitute vertex AI with Cloud composer
as mentioned previously or with another
orchestration tool
same with Cloud build and CI CD you
could use cyber positories or is
equivalent
we also added feature store so this will
enable you to share features reuse them
and also version your features
here is how a Vertex AI pipeline could
look like so each of these blocks you
see in this diagram is a vertex AI
component and it's a step in your ml
Pipeline and this could all be
orchestrated with additional features
such as runtime parameters and
conditionals
we're also very happy to announce that
now we have 20 plus pre-built bigquery
ml operators available for you
what this means is that previously you
would have to create your own custom
component if you were to use bigquery ml
in a Vertex Pipelines
but now we have 20 plus pre-built
components which are maintained and
supported by Google Engineers so this
enables you to deploy your bigquery ml
pipelines inside production in vertex AI
much faster
and lastly I want to leave you with a
very exciting private preview feature we
have on bigquery ML
B4 you can only use bigquery amount on
structured data but now you can actually
tap into the value of bigquery ml with
your unstructured data as well
this means that if you have a lot of
images or text files stored in Google
Cloud Storage you could lever leverage
big lake and bigquery ml to extract
value using machine learning
how can you do this
so I like to illustrate how you can do
this with an example of a hypothetical
customer this is a retail a real estate
customer who wants to predict the
click-through rate of homes on their
website
so the current models uses a lot of
structure data like the home location
the size of the house for instance to
train the model
however they may have thousands of
images stored on Google Cloud Storage
that's not taking consideration inside
the model today but this could drive a
lot of business insight
so if they want to use images they would
have to process the images separately
so how do we make this experience better
for them
so right now in private preview you can
create an object table in bigquery where
all the images in Google Cloud Storage
are indexed and you do this simply by
just creating object table this simple
SQL query pointing to each of the
location of your image
next you import your model inside
bigquery so right now you have your
computer vision model imported with a
create model and pointing to the
location of where your model is stored
and then afterwards you run a simple ml
predict using the model and the object
table to create latent representations
in a table which you could then join to
your on your structured data to power
your machine learning model training
so in three easy steps you can actually
have unstructured latent representations
embedded into your new model
and this is the last slide of our
presentation I'll leave you to enjoy the
rest of Google Cloud next thank you very
much
[Applause]
one by one I know we've seen so many
things
[Music]
hey so actually we've come to the end of
the technical content that will be live
streamed today but we're super excited
that we have a lot more going on here on
site so I just want to say I hope you've
been able to make the most of it and
thank you all online for your
participation and hope you have a chance
to sign up as an innovator for Google
Cloud so you have access to all of our
Live Events we find out where we're
hosting challenges near you in the
future
and sign up for the Drone Racing League
challenge as well
and those of you here I hope you had a
chance to interact with our Architects
play a couple games
um you know ask some questions get
involved in the Google Cloud community
so I'd really like to personally thank
you on behalf of all of the googlers
here and the local teams
we're looking to really bring more gcp
developer activities to all of you
locally and virtually
so what's happening now
well you are the heart of everything
that we do so that's why we decided to
make some Hands-On workshops for those
of you here locally Guided by our
experts and we'll have one here in this
main room and we'll have one upstairs
and unfortunately for those online we
have to say goodbye but again thank you
and the future is for developers that
we'll see each other again soon
we'll also have a reception for the
local folks here so after your Hands-On
Workshop which remember to get your swag
stamps for we'll then come back and
there'll be some changes and we'll have
a chance to have some food and some
drinks and connect even in a more casual
way so the other workshops are from
polong Ling and other Champion
innovators so that is the building and
end-to-end data and ml solution on gcp
workshop and the second one is upstairs
in our Atlanta room and that's a spark
for data engineers and data scientists
and that'll be with Brad Moreau
so you can take a quick break here and
then join the last workshop and then
we'll see each other for our
well-deserved celebration at the end
back here in the master Ballroom
all right thank you all ciao
[Music]